now i'm going to use this example as a
reason to bring in yesterday i told you
what the second derivative was
right we said that the second derivative
or maybe i should start again the first
derivative what feature what geometric
sort of quality does it tell you about
the graph
it tells you gradient okay we say the
second derivative tells you concavity
okay so how does that work well you
wouldn't have done this probably on your
question but let's do it now let's think
about the second derivative for these
questions
okay uh let's go with this one first
here
is my first derivative okay so what's my
second derivative
can you see it can you tell me
6x that's the first one plus 6 right
there's my second derivative okay so 6x
plus 6 what does this thing look like
this is 6 outside of x plus
one so it goes through negative one
which is here okay and then it's a steep
low so it looks like this
something like that okay you happy with
that there's my second derivative
now how can you use this to make sure
and confirm or get extra information
about your graph right
well look at these two stationary points
i found okay for instance
minus two four what value does the
second derivative have
at this point okay now you can go ahead
and actually put in minus 2 here
and you'll get minus 12 plus 6 so
that's the second derivative of minus 6
but it's really enough to just say well
look at this point the second derivative
is below the axis
so the second derivative is negative
what does that correspond to
this uh this stationary point is concave
down can you see it and just in the
reverse way this stationary point
is concave up okay do you see the
implication here
all right now this one's worth um
writing down on a separate
um spot so either you can go back to
where you wrote down your second
derivative notes
or you can rule off where you've drawn
your graphs and uh let me explain the
usefulness of this
so far we've seen if you wanted to
determine the nature of a stationary
point
what was the method do you remember we
had to draw up a
a sign table right and then we said a
turning point the derivative changes
side on either side the first derivative
right
but i don't have to do that anymore if
i've got the second derivative
does this make sense watch what happens
i want to test the nature
of my stationary points okay so here's
the way i'm going to do it
instead of saying here's a table and i'm
going to say
x and d y and dx and then i test
the station point and on either side
okay here's what i'll do instead
i'm going to get my second derivative
out which is
six x plus six
okay and i want to think about what it's
equal to
at both of these points right so you
write down when x
equals minus two okay the second
derivative is
uh we said minus twelve oh sorry minus
six i think
right minus six okay and this
is less than zero okay
second derivative is less than zero okay
now since second derivative tells you
about concavity right you say therefore
at x equals minus two it's concave down
now what does concave down mean it means
you're facing sad right
so that is a local maximum
okay this makes sense so before we
looked at
either side of the stationary point and
we saw okay it's going
up and then it's horizontal and then
it's going down and that tells you
it's a local maximum but a better way a
faster way of saying going up
and then horizontal and going down is
just saying it's concave down do you see
how they amount to the same thing
okay in the same way you test the other
one right
you say when x equals zero
uh the second derivative in this case
will be uh six
right
okay and that's positive
now i i know i got confused when i was
learning the first time
because it seems backwards because
concave down
negative right that means maximum okay
that's because it's facing down
so the picture you want to have in your
head is this that's a maximum you can
see that's a maximum so concave down
means max or here you're concave up
okay so in your head or on your page you
should draw this kind of picture because
that's concave up and that's a minimum
i probably should have said relative
sorry
rather than local